the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let's look at storyboard two we're going
to look in more detail at carbohydrate
catabolism at this point we're
eventually going to be doing the pathway
of glycolysis but we have to get there
first and it depends on what precursors
are available to enter the pathway of
glycolysis one option that we'll look at
a little bit later is to take in glucose
from the blood by way of a glucose
carrier and then phosphorylate the
glucose using either hexa kinase or
glucokinase the second option is to take
glycogen the polymeric storage form of
glucose integrated to glucose
1-phosphate which will be then converted
to glucose 6-phosphate which will enter
the pathway of glycolysis we're going to
start with this pathway of glycogen
breakdown or glycogenolysis panel a
shows the structure of glycogen which
consists of glucose monomeric units
connected by a bond between the 1 and 4
carbons in the Alpha configuration
chemistry is going to be happening at
the non-reducing end which is to the
left the reducing end which is to the
right is connected to a scaffolding
protein called glycogenin we'll come
back to glycogenin later in the course
let's look next at panel be the reaction
begins with the protonation of the red
oxygen between the terminal two glucose
moieties by a proton on the glycogen
phosphorylase enzyme the intermediate
product is a resonance stabilized pair
of positively charged species or cations
an oxonium ion at the 1 prime oxygen and
a carbo cation at the 1 carbon the
electrophilic carbon cation is attacked
by the negatively charged phosphate
residue which is non-covalently
associated with glycogen phosphorylase
to form glucose 1-phosphate note that
the glucose 1-phosphate that forms has
the covalently attached phosphate on the
Alpha or bottom face as it's drawn in
the figure the structure of glycogen
phosphorylase a allows attack of its
phosphate from the bottom giving rise to
alpha isomer only of glucose 1-phosphate
the structure of the phosphorylation
precludes access of its phosphate to the
top face of the sugar molecule so you
get only one stereoisomer of glue
one phosphate out of this reaction the
other product shown at the bottom of
panel C is the glycogen chain which is
truncated or shortened by one glucose
unit now looking at the big picture the
epinephrine molecule produced as part of
the stress response interacted with the
cell membrane of the muscle cell and
that interaction ultimately activated
glycogen phosphorylase to enable it to
degrade glycogen the storage form of
glucose and liberate glucose 1-phosphate
which is going to then find its way into
glycolysis to generate fast energy to
enable the student to be able to stand
up in class and avoid the stressful
situation I'm not going to go through
all of the details of the chemical
reactions of I Collis you can find those
in the book which does a good job of
prevent of presenting those details in
the first step of glycolysis we see the
phosphorylated hexose glucose
6-phosphate be converted by phospho
glucose isomerase into the furanose
fructose 6-phosphate the next step
involves the phosphorylation of the
fructose 6-phosphate by
phosphofructokinase one ATP is the
phosphate donor and you form fructose 1
6 bisphosphate as the product you'll
notice that phosphofructokinase
catalyzes one way or thermodynamically
irreversible reaction this step like
hexokinase we talked about earlier our
sites of regulation of the pathway the
word glycolysis comes from the Greek
word sugar splitting and we're now at
the step where the splitting of the
sugar from one six carbon compound into
two 3-carbon compounds occurs the enzyme
that splits the sugar in half is called
aldolase and again i advise you to take
a look at the book to see the detail of
the chemical reaction briefly the enzyme
is going to form a protonated schiff
base at the number 2 carbon of the
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate that
protonated schiff base is going to draw
electrons all the way over from the
hydroxyl group on carbon 4 of fructose 1
6 bisphosphate that movement of
electrons is going to result in cleavage
of the molecule into two parts at the
broken line and shown in the figure
carbons 1 2 & 3 are going to form DHAP
or dihydroxyacetone phosphate in
means four five and six are going to
form gap or glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate
gap in DHAP are the products of the
aldolase reaction as an aside this is
also a branch point in the pathway
dihydroxyacetone phosphate is an
opportunity for the cell to make the
glycerol backbone zuv liquids that we'll
come to later so we see here that
glycolysis is indeed a resource that can
be used for things other than energy
generation now let's look at panel B
imagine that a cell is committed to make
as much energy as it can for example the
stand up sit down scenario we talked
about earlier in that case the enzyme TI
m or triose phosphate isomerase is going
to interconvert very quickly
dihydroxyacetone phosphate and
glyceraldehyde 3 phosphate and
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate is going to
be the molecule that progresses along
the glycolysis pathway in the next step
of glycolysis glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
will be oxidized by
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate dehydrogenase
or gap d h again take a look at the
mechanism in the book in brief it
involves attack by a Thyle residue of a
gap d h cysteine on the aldehydic carbon
of glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate the
product is a thio hemiacetal which is
then oxidized its electrons are
transferred as hydride to nad plus on
the enzyme to form NADH this is the only
oxidation step in the pathway of
glycolysis the oxidation of the
hemiacetal produces the thio ester and
that die o ester is a very high energy
compound the thio ester is attacked by
inorganic phosphate to form an ACL
phosphate another high energy compound
which is called 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate
the ACO phosphate of 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate then phosphorylates
adp to form ATP in the first ATP forming
step of glycolysis keep in mind that two
molecules of gab have been formed in the
upstream part of the pathway so for each
molecule of glucose you're getting 2
molecules of ATP at this step the enzyme
that does this phosphorylation is
phosphoglycerate kinase
after 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate has lost
its terminal phosphate from the 1 carbon
it forms the acid 3-phosphoglycerate
as a reminder mute aces are enzymes that
move a functional group from one atom to
another on the same molecule the next
enzyme in the pathway is
phosphoglycerate mutase which in effect
moves the phosphate from the 3 to the 2
carbon forming 2-phosphoglycerate which
is the next intermediate in the
glycolysis pathway although it's easy to
say that the phosphate is quote-unquote
moved that is somewhat inaccurate if you
look at the details of the step in the
book you'll see that the reaction starts
with the transfer of a phosphate from
the mutase protein to the substrate 3
phosphoglycerate forming an intermediate
Biss phosphorylated product to 3
bisphosphoglycerate as an aside this is
the same powerful allosteric effector
that joanne described when she taught us
about how small molecules can
dramatically reduce the affinity of
hemoglobin for oxygen in the case of the
mutase however the enzyme will take the
phosphate off of the 3 hydroxyl of 2 3
bisphosphoglycerate in the enzyme will
reef us for allayed itself so the final
product of the fossil glyceride mutation
reaction is 2 phosphoglycerate
now let's turn to storyboard four in
panel a we see the enzyme inna Lay's
which removes the hydrogen from the to
carbon of 2-phosphoglycerate
this is not an easy task the PK of that
hydrogen is about 30 nevertheless the
reaction does occur and liberates water
the product is phosphoenolpyruvate
usually abbreviated PEP or pep a very
high energy compound we are now almost
at the end of the pathway of glycolysis
and as I mentioned earlier one usually
looks for highly exergonic steps near
the beginnings or ends of pathways to
see where the pathway is regulated
pyruvate kinase or PK the last step in
the pathway is such a regulation point
the pyruvate kinase reaction occurs in
two steps in the first step
fostro enol pyruvate phosphorylates adp
to form ATP the enol product then
undergoes enol keto tautomer ization
yielding the ketone pyruvate and
pyruvate is the end of the pathway let's
turn now to story board five panel a
let's take a look at this pathway from a
higher altitude first as I just
mentioned the pathway is regulated at
the top and bottom specifically at the
hexokinase step the glycogen
phosphorylase step and the pyruvate
kinase step it's also regulated in the
middle specifically at the
phosphofructokinase one-step regulation
can be allosteric which we shall see is
the case with pfk it also can be
covalent we saw that this is the case
with glycogen phosphorylase or GP the
last lecture we'll take a look at
regulation of these enzymes in great
detail as a second issue let's now look
at the pathway as drawn in summary form
and panel b of this story board we start
with a single molecule of the six carbon
sugar glucose hexokinase or glucokinase
will utilize one ATP to form a
phosphorylated intermediate
phosphofructokinase one will use a
second ATP to form a doubly
phosphorylated hexose fructose 1 6
bisphosphate this phosphorylated hexose
will split into two trioses
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate and
dihydroxyacetone
phosphate these are interconvertible the
chemical species
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate is subject to
oxidation because we get two molecules
of gap four molecule of glucose gap
oxidation will produce two molecules of
NADH in the next step we're going to
make two ATP's using the enzyme
phosphoglycerate kinase at this point
we're ATP neutral with consume two ATP's
and we've generated two ATP's and lastly
the enzyme pyruvate kinase is going to
generate an additional two ATP's I put
those in a box because these are the two
net ATP s for the whole pathway so
that's the pathway of glycolysis I want
to give you a little bit of a preview of
coming attractions at this point what
you'll notice is that the pathway
involves an oxidation step in which we
consumed two nad+ molecules and
generated two NADH s nad plus is derived
from a vitamin we only have limited
amounts of it we need to find a way to
regenerate the nad plus in order to
process the next molecule of glucose and
we'll see that nature has several ways
to solve that problem nature actually
has three ways to regenerate NAD+ the
first we'll call alcoholic fermentation
the second is homoleptic fermentation
and the third is respiration alcoholic
fermentation and Homo lactic
fermentation occur in the absence of
oxygen that is in aerobic Li respiration
by definition is an aerobic process now
we'll look at each of these mechanisms
of regeneration of nad plus in some
detail but also in addition to nad plus
you're going to have to generate a
number of other products that can be
useful to the cell we'll see those later
let's look at panel C under anaerobic
conditions yeast will take pyruvate and
convert it initially to acetaldehyde and
then reduce the acid aldehyde to ethanol
these are the reactions of alcoholic
fermentation yeast uses an enzyme called
pyruvate decarboxylase to process the
pyruvate pyruvate decarboxylase or PDC
has on it a covalently attached thiamine
pyrophosphate
diamond is derived from vitamin b1 as we
go through the pyruvate decarboxylase
reactions at the outset I want you to
keep in mind that PDC pyruvate
decarboxylase is very similar to the
front end of the chemical reaction
series that's conducted by an enzyme
present in mammals like us that enzyme
complex is pyruvate dehydrogenase which
will come to a little later when we talk
about respiration the thiazole ring in
TPP forms an Illit that means that
despite the fact that the pKa of the
diamond pyrophosphate is about 19 you
are able to form a carbon ion at the
carbon of the thiazole neom ring system
that carbon ion attacks the middle
carbon of pyruvate converting it from a
ketone to an alcohol now you have the
thigh ozone liam ring system with the
positive charge beta to the carboxylate
of pyruvate that system readily
decarboxylase as shown liberating
thiamine pyrophosphate in the product
acid aldehyde the next enzyme in this
small pathway is alcohol dehydrogenase
which utilizes nadh which came in in
principle from the gap th step of
glycolysis alcohol dehydrogenase uses
the glycolysis derived NADH to reduce
the aldehyde functionality of acid
aldehyde to form the product of this
pathway ethanol ethanol is an alcohol
hence the name alcoholic fermentation so
looking at this small pathway in total
what you see is that you form co2 as a
first product which could be the bubbles
in a carbonated beverage or what makes
bread rise and form ethanol is the other
major product and of course you get your
nad Plus back which you can then return
to glycolysis specifically the gap th
step of glycolysis to enable metabolic
processing of the next molecule of
glucose so this is the pathway that
yeast and other alcohol forming
organisms use to maintain redox
neutrality within the cell I'm on
storyboard six and we're going to start
with panel D the second general
mechanism that we're going to look at
that concerns the regeneration of Na
Plus for glycolysis is called Homo
lactic fermentation
this occurs in mammals and in lactic
acid bacteria and like alcoholic
fermentation it is also a process that
occurs anaerobically that is in the
absence of oxygen as you can see
pyruvate is a keto acid and the ketone
at the number 2 carbon can be easily
reduced in this case NADH will transfer
hydride to the ketone in order to reduce
it to the alcohol lactate the net
reaction here involves consumption of
one NADH in the production of one nad
plus and this nad plus of course can go
back and be utilized to enable oxidation
of the next molecule of glucose passing
through the glycolytic pathway when a
mammal is running hard this is the
pathway by which we achieve redox
neutrality and glycolysis when we
exercise intensely lactate is produced
in excess to keep the glycolytic pathway
active the lactate causes the blood pH
to go down that is the because the blood
becomes more acidic because lactic acid
has a low PKA i also want to point out
that this in aerobic pathway is also the
basis for production of lactate by
lactic acid bacteria which is critical
to the manufacturing of yoghurt let's
look now at panel II the third pathway
to regenerate NAD+ for glycolysis is
respiration we're going to be going
through respiration in some detail later
but right now I'm going to give you a
very high-level view of it in the way of
an introduction the mitochondrial inner
membrane is very well equipped to be
able to transport electrons those
electrons will travel along an electron
transport chain to oxygen reducing the
oxygen we breathe into water this is a
highly energy generating process and the
energy that's generated is part of the
driving force for the synthesis of ATP
the details of how our respiring
organism generates ATP is covered later
for right now however let's just say
that the mitochondrial membrane oxidizes
NADH to regenerate the nad plus needed
to sustain glycolysis and again we'll
see the details of how this happens
later later I'll also cover the ways
that redox
allottee is maintained in a mammalian
cell in brief NAD+ is generated from
nadh and ii robes by a series of
reactions that i call quote unquote the
shuttles which will be covered in
section 12 before we go on let me give
you a little recap of where we are we've
seen that there are a couple of optional
beginning sir glycolysis it can begin
with intake of glucose from the blood or
it can begin with the breakdown of
glycogen by glycogenolysis the formal
pathway takes glucose as glucose
6-phosphate down to pyruvate we get a
total of two ATP's in that process and
we produce two NADH s now however we've
got to have a way to be able to
regenerate our nad plus from those any D
H's in order to be able to make the
pathway ready to process the next
molecule of glucose accordingly nature
developed three endings to the pathway
that result in the regeneration of nad
plus these endings are alcoholic
fermentation homo lactic fermentation
and respiration looking at the picture
in panel II once again in us respiration
happens in the mitochondrion primarily
in the mitochondrial inner membrane and
in the jelly-like mitochondrial matrix
pyruvate generated in the cytoplasm
that's the compartment where glycolysis
occurs goes through the porous outer
membrane of the mitochondrion then the
pyruvate encounters the membrane bound
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex which is
our next topic in bacteria which are in
many ways like mitochondria respiration
happens in the cellular membrane and in
the cell's cytoplasm let's take a look
at panel a of storyboard seven we're
about to start our discussion of
respiration which is the oxidative
metabolism of all metabolic fuels via
the common intermediate acetyl co a in
mammals as I said earlier these are
mitochondrial reactions at the outset I
also want to point out that we have seen
that carbohydrates can be metabolized
either anaerobically or aerobically as
we'll see when we use lipids as our
metabolic fuels they can only be
metabolized aerobically
limpets break down to a Sat Eelco a
which is then oxidized by the TCA cycle
let's take a look at panel B when we
talked about alcoholic fermentation
earlier I said that yeast have a
pyruvate decarboxylase complex and i
said that the reactions of the of the
pyruvate decarboxylase complex are very
similar to the reactions in the early
part of the pyruvate dehydrogenase
reaction which is a little bit more
complex pyruvate dehydrogenase has three
activities II 1 e 2 and e 3 as with
pyruvate decarboxylase II one has a
diamond pyrophosphate unit TPP and the
illud on the TPP attacks the middle
carbon of the pyruvate specifically its
ketone carbon at this point you're going
to want to take a look at detailed notes
that I've provided as supplemental
material this supplemental material will
be referred to as slide 1 slide 2 and so
on looking at slide 1 you can see the
decarboxylation happens exactly the same
way that I described for the pyruvate
decarboxylase system now take a look at
slides 2 through 6 in the case of pdh
pyruvate dehydrogenase unlike the
situation with PDC pyruvate
decarboxylase restructuring of the
carboxy ethyl group is going to result
in the formation of a carbon ion that's
going to attack the disulfide of lipoic
acid looking at slide 7 you'll see the
conversion of the hydroxy ethyl to a
keto functionality jettisons the TPP
resulting in a thio ester in which
there's an acyl group connected to
lipoic acid at this point the thigh all
of coenzyme a attacks the keto oxygen of
the thio ester producing acetyl co a
which is going to become a very
important molecule as we move ahead the
second product is reduced lipoic acid
technically the formation of reduced
lipoic acid is the oxidation step of the
pyruvate dehydrogenase reaction the
decarboxylation step that happened a few
steps earlier is basically the reduction
of co2 that we eventually will breathe
out when we exhale
now let's look at slide a the reducing
equivalents on the e2 subunits present
as reduced lipoic acid will move across
the e2 subunit toward the e3 subunit the
e3 subunit has an oxidized disulfide
bond on it which was created by the
connection of 2 cysteines on the protein
that oxidized disulfide is then reduced
by transfer of the reducing equivalents
from the reduced lipoic acid to the
disulfide and then finally the reducing
equivalents are passed from the reduced
disulfide 2f ad to form fadh2 that fadh2
passes along its reducing equivalents to
nad plus forming NADH this NADH is
soluble and will move to its next
location specifically this NADH will
return to the mitochondrial membrane
actually to another place in the
mitochondrial membrane an enzyme called
complex 1 and be oxidized in the
electron transport chain overall one
pyruvate enters the pdh complex we lose
its carboxylate as co2 we generate from
pyruvates residue and acetate coenzyme a
and at the very end we get an NADH which
will then go on to the electron
transport complex to be oxidized the
formation of nad plus as I mentioned
above is critical to allow further
oxidation of reduced that is energy rich
molecules such as glucose